we're going to build like the greatest
shooter okay so we're gonna choose
someone's release and we'll choose
someone's balance someone's footwork and
we'll build the best person release
probably Larry Bird or kind of Reggie
Miller combined higher releases so can't
really block it as well what about
footwork hi Clay Thompson his foundation
is always just solid you know he's
coming off screens he's always just
facing the basket never like off balance
I feel like I'm gonna know the answer to
this one but range
[Laughter]
off the dribble Paul George he's just so
versatile with you know his height and
his size the way he can still handle the
ball and I try to take a lot of that
stuff and utilize that in practice
prettiest shot Klay Thompson it's just
like the same every time he's squaring
just straight so what would you take
from Grady dick my release point and
just the quick quickness of it